hello everyone out there on free code
camp my name is anu cooper and i'm a
software developer as well as your guide
for this fun javascript tutorial
in this javascript tutorial we're going
to be building two word games that is a
jeopardy game that i've adapted to work
well for one player and a game of word
association
this tutorial will be for those who have
learned the basics of javascript and
just want to practice some fun games
okay so there'll be a lot of work with
objects arrays loops and everything like
that
in fact here is a full list of all the
javascript properties and methods we
will be using in this tutorial
so let's dissect the first game the
first game will be my adapted game of
jeopardy as you can see here the signing
is very basic this is a javascript
tutorial okay i won't be focusing that
much on the styling because that part is
up to you
in this game when you flip a card you
won't be able to flip any of the other
cards until you answer the question and
if you answer correctly you get some
points and of course if you don't well
no points for you
and in the next game of word association
you will have some cards which will be
populated from an array and you have to
essentially get the word associated with
the three tips above if you get the
answer correct you get a point and if
you don't that's minus a point for you
the total amount of points will be
reflected based on the amount of correct
and wrong answers you choose
okay so what are we waiting for let's
get to practicing some javascript
okay so let's get started i'm going to
start off with first off creating my
project i am using webstorm as my code
editor or technic ide of choice but
please feel free to use whatever code
editor you wish such as vs code or you
know similar
okay so what i'm going to do is just go
ahead and create a new project and i'm
going gonna call this
word
association
game
okay so that's all i'm gonna call it and
it's gonna be stored in my webstorm
projects directory and i'm just going to
go ahead and click create
so there we go you will see a directory
called word association game that has
been created
the next thing i want to do is actually
add the files necessary so this is going
to be an html file i'm just going to
call this index html you can put the
extension but as i have chosen the html
file it will just be added for me so
there we go we are telling our code
editor of choice to treat this as an
html file
great and i'm just going to call this
word association
okay
maybe let's make it a little bit bigger
so there we have it the next file we're
going to create is for our style sheet
so i'm going to click style sheet and
let's call this styles and i'm just
going to select the css file for those
of you not using webstorm just type css
and that should be created for you so
now our code editor knows to treat this
as a css file
one more and that is a javascript file
so this one i'm just going to call app
and hit enter once again if you are not
using web store make sure to put in the
dot js extension so that your code
editor knows to treat this as a
javascript file
great
so now that we have all three files what
i need to do is connect these two files
to my index.html file so we're going to
do so now with a link tag and a script
tag
so stylesheets we actually do this in
between the two head tags i'm going to
get the link tag like so so this is
actually a self-closing tag
and i'm just going to put the
rel as style sheet
and the href is just going to be the
part where our style sheet lives well
it's in the root of our project so i'm
just going to type in
styles
css okay we don't need to go into any
directories or anything like that it's
just a very simple project everything is
just in here
and now for the script tag so the script
tag we're gonna have to make sure to put
this at the bottom of our body so once
any sort of uh
i guess elements we want to put in so if
we put in elements here
we need to put the script tag afterwards
okay so make sure that's at the bottom
of your two body tags and i'm just going
to put the source again as the
path to the app.js file
so great
now you will see some code being
suggested for me so as you can see this
is being suggested for me if you aren't
seeing this this is because i am using
the tab 9 extension which will give me
next generation code snippet suggestions
so if you aren't seeing that don't worry
there's nothing wrong with your code
editor it's just a uh
extension that i have installed
okay
so great so we've linked up our style
sheet we've linked up our app js file
the next thing to do is actually start
adding some stuff into my html file in
order to start building up you know the
skeleton of our word associated game
this is a javascript tutorial so the
majority of our work is actually going
to be done in the app.js file but a
small piece of um html is still kind of
needed
so i'm going to put in a div let's give
this the class of app
so we can pick it out later in our css
and style it up
so here is our app and what do i want to
put in the app well i'm going to have a
question area so i'm going to put div
and give this the class of
question
area like so so that we can once again
pick it out in our
css file to style it up now my question
area well one thing i definitely want to
have and i don't want to change is just
going to be you know the header of the
app this is going to say
welcome
to
word association okay and then let's
also have an h3 tag which is going to
show us our score and this will change
so i'm just going to put your score is
and then i'm going to use a span
element
okay the span element allows to
interrupt this h3 tag in line so it
won't do anything funky it'll all still
look like it's part of you know i guess
one sentence uh and the score well we're
gonna have to inject this with our
javascript which is why i want to pick
out this span element and i'm gonna do
so by giving this an id
so the id i'm gonna give this is school
display
just
like so so now i can pick it out
with my javascript
okay
so we have the question area it's got
the h1 tag it's got an h3 tag the next
thing i want to do is add a div and i'm
going to give this the class so we can
style it up of questions
okay but i'm also going to give this the
id so we can also pick it out in our
javascript we can pick it out by class
but it's just meter i think to do it by
ids
but again each to your own there's so
many ways you can code this game it's
absolutely crazy
so we've given a class so we can silent
up we've also given this id so we can
pick it out in our javascript and
essentially what we're going to be doing
is injecting we're going to be injecting
elements into here
using javascript so i hope you're
excited for this that's why we're
picking this out we're going to be
literally appending
elements into here all in here
great
so we're pretty much done with this page
now let's move on to the
app.js
pile so the first thing i said we're
going to do is just pick out this
element right well we're going to pick
up both these elements maybe let's start
with the score first what should we save
this as i'm going to say this is called
display
it's gonna make it a little bit bigger
for you we can actually minimize this
so score display i'm gonna use document
because i'm looking in the entire html
document the whole thing i'm gonna use
get element by id and i'm gonna get it
by score display making sure it's
spelled exactly the same way
that we spelt it here so now we've
picked out this entire thing
okay because we're going to want to
inject
the score into here
the same for the
question display because we're going to
inject elements into here so what should
we call this
well for consistently i'm just going to
call it question display and if i hit
enter that's actually been auto
completed for me by tap nine so there we
go we are picking things out we're
saving them as cons so that we can use
them later on in our code
so great so now that we have that let's
carry on the first thing i actually want
to do is actually just write some
questions that we're going to be you
know displaying in our word association
game so i'm going to show you how to do
that it's going to be an array so i'm
going to call this const questions and
make an array and it's going to be an
array of objects okay
so each object is going to contain you
know the actual
uh
words so we're going to have
three words and then we're going to have
to pick
a answer based of two words that the
um
word is most associated with i didn't
explain that very well but hopefully i'm
going to show you now how to do it and
then we're also going to tell ourselves
which is the correct score
so for example if i have three words
and those words are going to be
value and then the next word is going to
be estimate
and then the third word is going to be a
value wait
so we've got three words
as the quiz words and then our options
to select from as in which word is most
likely
associated with these three words well
the first one i'm going to put is jury
which doesn't really
make sense right jury isn't associated
with these three words however
assess
is
okay so the viewer is going to see these
three words and then have the option of
these two to pick which one is more
associated with these three
so and then i'm also going to put that
the correct answer is option two out of
these we could go by index like zero or
one it's up to you i'm not going to just
purely because i do do this video
in on my personal channel using an api
and that api actually happens to use
this format so not using indexes but
just simply saying that option one is
not correct but option two is correct so
that's why i've done it this way again
it's up to you how you would like to do
it
so there's our first question let's go
ahead and create some more so for now
i'm just going to make a few of course
you can have as many as you like like i
did say i do do this tutorial on my own
channel using an api that actually gets
loads of loads of questions there's a
huge amount so if you want to check it
out please do use the link in my
description below in order to
essentially
get
the link for this
a tutorial
okay so these are just hard-coded for us
as i mentioned okay so i'm just going to
paste another three that i pre-made
earlier
so there
we
go
okay those three i've just pasted in
please pause here if you need or the
code will be available in the
description below as well
so those are my five questions along
with the correct answers okay so when
are you going to use this array in order
to
create new elements using loops okay
so this means that if you want to add
more questions then you know
each the elements will be easily created
for us and so on
so the first thing that i'm gonna do is
well actually let's start with the score
so the score is gonna change which is
why i've used let and now it's not good
enough just saying that the score is
zero we're gonna have to actually put it
into our html and we're going to do so
because we've already picked out the
score display
so i can use this const
and i'm going to use text content and
i'm just going to use the score variable
okay so that's all i've done and now
making sure that's just one equals
and now if i view this so i'm just going
to open this up
in webstorm i can actually just use this
button right here and that will open up
in my browser
okay so you will see the score has been
added
wonderful
for those of you not using webstorm you
can just copy the path so you'd copy
the path here and then paste it in your
browser so i'm just going to do it
for you i'm going to get the absolute
path
and then paste it in here like so it's
the same thing
great
it's going to minimize this again
so
wonderful so we are showing the score
the next thing that we're going to do is
write a function to
populate the questions so just like we
got the score display here we're going
to now get the question display and
populate it with questions so i'm going
to do this all in a self-contained
function however so the function is
going to be called populate
questions okay it's just what i've
chosen to call it
now
we're going to actually use four each so
essentially a loop in order to create a
bunch of divs that are going to be our
question boxes they're going to hold all
the question stuff together
so based on how many items i have in
this array so i'm going to get this
array
i'm getting the array i'm going to use
four each and for each item in my array
now we know there's five items i'm going
to choose to call those items each one
of them a question
so for each
item which i have chosen to call
question what i want to do is
essentially create an element i want to
create a
diff okay and let's just save this as
question
box so we can use it in our
javascript const
question
box
now i'm actually going to add a class
list
so we can do so with class
list add and i'm going to add the class
of question
box
to
the div that we just
created okay so that is how you would do
it you would use this method in order to
add the question box class to the div we
just created of course we won't be able
to see anything quite yet we haven't
styled any divs and we haven't actually
put that div back into the html
so i'm going to show you how to do that
next
so for
now what can we do maybe let's start up
the question box just so we can see
things visually first
so i'm just going to maybe make this a
little bit bigger and grab the question
box like so and let's do some styling
so my question boxes at the moment i'm
just going to give them a background
color uh i'm just going to use an rgb
color for this
just
so
and give each one a margin of 15 pixels
okay
so that's all i am going to do just so
we can start seeing some things so we've
created a div we added the class of
question box to it which is essentially
just make it black or the margin the
next thing we need to do is put the
question box
into
our question display
so we can do so let's get the question
display
display i'm going to use append to put
in the question box
okay and then i'm just going to call the
function so i'm just going to call it
to make this work
and now if i refresh this you will see
there are five question boxes in here we
need to put something in them in order
to actually see that they are black so
all i'm gonna do
is go back in here
and for now just so you can see that
this is actually working i'm just going
to put
box
okay so just put the string of box
so there
we
go box box
box
perhaps maybe let's you know give this
text
let's make it white
just so we can see what is going on
if i'm just going to make it slightly
off-white
so rgb
230 230
230.
great
so amazing we are looping in order to
get question boxes made for each of our
questions
let's carry on so hopefully that makes
sense because we're going to be using
this logic a lot in this tutorial we're
just going to be kind of repeating this
in order to create more elements okay
great
while we are here i'm actually just
going to grab the app itself so the div
with the class of app just to make sure
that everything is centered and i'm
actually going to apply the font family
of trebuchet sounds to it as well so
it's a tribute ms sorry
and then just some backup ones too so
maybe let's have lucinda
grande vadana sure those ones
so to center everything i'm going to use
display flex so this is flexbox
okay you have to use display flex in
order to
do these next few
lines otherwise they will not be applied
so justify content comes with flexbox
and then text align does not actually
come with flexbox so text align center
that's just to center all the text and
i'm going to give it a padding of 100 so
the app is going to have a padding of
100 pixels
great
and now the question boxes live in the
questions div right so we're inserting
them in here so i'm just going to style
up this div a little bit too
i just want to make sure i'm going to
use flexbox again by the way i'm going
to use display
flex and i just want to make sure that
they wrap okay so if you change the size
of your screen they kind of wrap over
each other and you do so with flex wrap
wrap and i'm also going to center them
so justify content center
wonderful and i'm just going to start
the question box a little bit more
um let's make give them a border radius
i'm a big fan of the border radius not
to make things look harsh i think it's
always like quite a nice thing to do i
think three is fine maybe let's go for
10 pixels
i'm also going to give a padding but the
padding is not going to be equal i'm
going to give it padding 0 from the top
40 pixels
to the right 10 pixels on the bottom and
40 pixels to the left
okay
so that's what i've done
great
so that is our question
box looking good and if we look in here
it just kind of looks more like that now
okay so each question box is ready to
have our questions we actually put into
them as well as you know some buttons uh
and so on so let's continue
so back here
so instead of having this just say box
we're actually going to
use four each to
show each of the three quiz
words from this array okay so we're
going to do that
next
so again this is going to be a for each
we're going to go into the questions
array we're then going to go into the
array and then find the quiz
key
and then we're going to use four each
and for each
one of these what should we call this i
guess it's a tip right we can call it a
tip for each tip
so tip we are going to essentially
create a
p tag
so document create element and the
element we want to create is a p tag
okay so that's all i'm going to do and
let's save this as const
tip
text
okay
again you can call it whatever you wish
so we've created a p tag the next thing
we're going to do is add a uh we're not
going to add a class lips we're going to
get the tip text and we're going to use
text content you can use in html it's
whatever you want to do and then we're
just going to assign the tip itself okay
so we're just going to assign fast and
then quick and then prompt okay
and then finally of course we need to
put it in something but we want to put
it in the question box this time okay
the question box we put into the
question display but into this okay so
let's go back here the question box this
thing let's look in here
so i'm going in
here's our html and then we grab this
this is the question display and we
inject these question boxes now in each
question box we also want to inject the
tips right so we're going to do that
so i'm going to this time get the
question box that we created up here and
i'm going to use append
tip text
okay
so now if we look in here
so once again see we're just adding
elements
adding them using javascript so now each
question box has p tags with our tips
great
okay so hopefully this is solidifying a
bit more the more we do it
let's
carry
on i also want to put in a logo so let's
do that above here so before these get
injected in the question box because
they do kind of stack up when you inject
things so you need to make sure that
whatever order
uh you want to put things in has to go
from top to bottom
so let's call this logo
um
yeah let's just call it all logo display
sure and i'm going to create a
element
actually let's make an h1 tag because
our logo is actually just gonna be some
symbol okay off the internet
of course you don't have to you can make
an image or something but what i'm gonna
do is go logo display so i'm gonna grab
this logo display
and i'm going to use text content
and i'm going to use this
because it's a web association game i'm
going to use this pen symbol right here
okay so that's all i've done it's just a
text symbol so we've added that and of
course once again we need to put it in
the question box we're going to get our
question
box and we're going to append you can
append child append actually allows you
to add multiple things
where a child just allows you to append
one i believe and the thing we're gonna
append is the logo display after we've
added some text to it
so great so once again if i refresh this
there is our
logo
cool of course we can style it up as
well if we wish
a simple way to do this without giving
this a class name actually
so that we you know we don't want too
much too much overkill is i can actually
go into the question
box and any h1 tag that lives in it will
have this styling so i'm just going to
make it go left by going a light text
align
left
and let's maybe change its color too so
i'm going to go rgb 177. one three six
two
one
one
okay but of course if you put in any h1
tags into the question box this will
have the same styling so just keep that
in mind
but otherwise it looks like this
great so we have our tips the next thing
we do is our two buttons that will show
us the two
potential
answers we could have so let's do that
next
so
we've just added the tips here
and we are putting the question box into
the question displays but before we do
that we need to do some more
stuff
so the next thing you want to do is
actually create a div that will store
our two buttons so that we can keep them
together so i'm going to use document
create
element and i'm going to create a
div
just
like so and let's store this as
question
buttons is this going to hold our
question buttons
and this time i will actually be adding
a class list to this so question button
class list add question buttons thank
you tab nine and of course also we need
to append it so this time i'm just gonna
go
grab the question box again
and append
question buttons
okay so we've put in the div that has
the class of question buttons into the
question box the next thing we need to
do is add some actual buttons into
the questions buttons this time
so i want to do this we are still in the
loop so if you can see here for each
question which make sure you're still in
between these curly braces because we're
looping over each one of these okay one
two three four five and in the loop i
want to get the options
okay so we've called each item in the
loop question
which means i'm going to get the
question
quiz
and for each quiz item what do we want
to call this for each first for each
option let's call it
well what do i want to do i want to
create a button so let's use document
create element
button
i'm going to save this as the const
question
button okay so singular this time
so we're essentially creating two
buttons as we have two items in the quiz
array
and now i'm just going to give this a
class list so question button classlet
add question button singular
okay of course we are yet to write this
class and i'm just going to give it some
text content too so we can see what's
going on question button text content
and that's going to be the option
okay and of course let's not forget that
we need to actually append this into the
question
buttons
so i'm gonna put it in here question
buttons append
the
question
button singular okay so it's gonna loop
once it's gonna put in the first one
it's gonna loop a second time it's gonna
put in the second one after of course we
assign at the class list and assign it
the actual option itself
so let's have a look in here
and
ta-da we've picked the wrong thing
i mean that's good right we are figuring
this out it's not questions quiz it's
question
it's option so each of the questions
options
so
ta-da so we are doing it we have our two
options
this is looking good let's take a break
from some javascript and start this up a
little bit more
okay because we still have a bit to do
we need to add an event listener to the
question button itself that's going to
check for answers disable boston's make
sure we can't click on a button again
and so on so let's take a quick break
and relax our brains with some styling
so
let's actually pick out the
question buttons and question button to
style up
so i'm just going to use the class of
question buttons
and i want to make sure that everything
in here so the two buttons that we
created will be next to each other so
i'm going to use display flex and just
to be sure i'm going to give it a flex
direction of
not column
but
row and now for each individual question
button
i'm going to give each one a margin of 5
pixels
some padding 10 pixels from the top and
bottom and 20 from the left and right
i'm going to give it a border radius
which is going to be 20 pixels
be sure to spell that correctly
i'm going to say border none so we get
rid of the generic uh button styling and
then background color i'm just going to
go with rgb75134111
okay and the text is just going to be
white but i would like to make it rgb
so
maybe let's make a tiny bit off white
rgb 255.255.255.
great
however if we also then get the uh
question button
and if we add disabled to it
this is going to be for later i actually
want the background color to be like a
dark gray
rgb
eight nine one eight nine one eight nine
something like that maybe even a little
bit darker
okay of course that hasn't happened yet
but when we do disable the buttons uh
because we will be doing that that's
just what i want to do and then also the
text i want to look kind of like it's
grayish as well so it looks like we
can't click on it
great so now let's
carry on this is what our buttons should
look like right
now
okay as you can see these are wrapping
just
like
so i'm just going to make this movie a
little bit smaller
or a little bit bigger
it's totally up to you how you want to
view
this
let's move on so now that we have that
let's actually add an event listener to
our buttons so that it handles checking
for results
so we're going to do that here
so again we're going to grab the
question button so the question button
that we just created and use add event
listener to listen up for clicks
and if a click
is done we want to check
answer
so this is a callback function that we
are yet to write
okay in fact just for now i'm just gonna
do this down here i'm gonna write
function check answer
i'm just gonna console
log
checked
just so we can see this is working
okay
again inspect this page
get the console log up and if i click on
any button it'll say checked see checked
check check check check check
so we know that has been hooked up the
event listener is working
let's carry on
now
we don't just want the console log to
say something right what do we want to
happen well let's think about it
i actually want to check
if
the answer is correct and we already
have this data stored in an array and if
it is correct i wanted to say correct
below or if it's wrong i want it to say
wrong and i also want to disable the
button because we clicked on it we can't
click it again and if it's correct i
want to add a score and if it's wrong i
want to minus a score okay so by the end
you have a final score that's based off
how many wrong and right answers that
you have
cool
so
let's do it let's do all of that logic
next
so to do this i'm actually going to have
to pass some things through
into my check answer function so i'm
going to pass some things through so
i've got to open up my parentheses but
uh oh this means i'm calling the
function it's not a callback function
anymore so we need to do this to make it
a callback function okay otherwise this
will just check answer without me
clicking i'll just be like blah open
because obviously we're using brenda is
parenthesis so it's going like and
releasing all of its function
wonderfulness
so make sure to write that in order to
make this a callback function again
and the things we're going to have to
pass through
uh well
let's have a think about
this
i actually want to pass through
well i want to pass through the
i definitely want to pass through the
option
so by that means i want to pass through
this
i'm going to pass through this and then
i'm also going to pass
through
whichever index this is because we know
that for example
this is the correct answer
right
it says two so we're going to pass
through
the questions
correct
answer i'm also going to pass through
the option that we clicked and then it's
index value
okay where it sits in this array
so
let's
do that
now so we're going to have to give this
an index so i'm going to choose to call
this option
index
so for example i'm just going to show
you
what i mean by this
i'm going to pass through the option
and i'm going to pass through the option
index
and here i'm just going to console log
the option
that i've passed through so let's pass
through the option
and then let's also console
log
the option
index
okay
and if i go in here
let's click on option
one two
click
so option we clicked on is assessed the
option is passing through the option
index is not defined why is that let's
go back here
passing through the option index
but we're not passing it through into
the check answers function
so now let's click on this one great the
option is assessed and the option index
is one because this says option index
zero okay so each of them this would be
zero one zero one you can check it
that's what it should be
so we want a way to say
that you know the correct aren't we to
also post you the correct answer so
let's go ahead and do that
we need the questions
correct answer
so we know this is either going to be a
one or two right so let's change the
option index let's add plus one to it so
instead of dealing with indexes we're
just literally going it's either option
one or two so that correlates with the
way that we are counting the correct
answer here so it's one or two
so we just need to know that if this
equals this
then it's correct right
so let's pass that through i'm gonna
name it something else here because as
long as it's in the correct order it
we don't have to call it the same thing
in fact it'll be probably less confusing
if we just call this the
correct
answer
right okay so this means that if
it's going to move this up
if
option index equals the correct answer
it doesn't really need to be strict
then we know that it is well
correct let's just put that back in
there because it's shouting at me
so then we'll just add one to the score
right and of course we need to display
the score so score display text content
score because otherwise we add into the
score but we're not updating our browser
to show the new score so that line is
important
okay so that's all i am doing else
if it's not we're gonna minus one from
the score and again we need to show this
new score right because it's not good
enough just updating the screen here we
need to actually show that in the
browser
too
great so let's check it out
so if i click assess cool i get one to
the score because it's right and if i
click jury well minus has been added
because we know that is wrong so this is
working this is looking good however
look we can cheat right and also be
quite nice to disable the button if
we've clicked on it already so let's
work on disabling the buttons now
to do this we're actually going to have
to collect which items we have already
clicked so i'm going to make an array
let's go ahead and maybe do that here
so let's click since we might want to
you know
change that could be con let's just keep
it as let for now just
because i'm not exactly sure what i want
to do this yet so here's our array
and if we click on something well no
matter if it's right or wrong i'm just
going to put it in the array so here's
my array i'm going to push the option in
so this means actually i'm just going to
console log out the clicked array for us
here
so no matter if it's right or wrong
we're just collecting things in our
clicked
array
right
we're collecting them so that we know
this is clicked and we're going to
disable buttons thanks to this
so great just get rid of that
so this means that actually maybe let's
pass through the question button in here
as well into the check answer
function
so the actual button itself because we
can do that
you can do pretty much anything
and now we're going to get the question
button
and disabled
is not going to be true we're actually
going to look in the clicked array
and if the clicked array includes
the option
then we know so the option that we
clicked then we know that the button
should be disabled
so let's try it out click was disabled
click disabled yes
this is looking awesome
how cool is
this
amazing
so great
now one last thing it would be quite
nice to have you know like a display
right or wrong under here right so that
we know immediately if we are right or
wrong so i'm going to show you how to do
that
now
in fact
okay
we are going to
create
so at the bottom once we've put in
everything i'm actually going to create
put in another div that's going to show
our answer
so i'm going to do so right at the
bottom here so i'm going to use document
create element i'm going to create a
div this time and i'm going to call it
answer display
and we're going to get the answer
display and i'm going to
give it the class list
classless ad of answer display which
we're going to start up later and of
course we need to put this into our
question box so question box append
answer
display
and now let's style it up a little bit
perhaps we should just we can do that so
i'm going to get in my css file
let's get our answer display
and i'm going to just actually hard code
a height for this so no matter if it's
empty or not it's going to have the same
height and i'm just going to center
everything in here so once again i'm
going to use flexbox display flex align
item center justify content center
so there we have it okay so we've got
our
answer display
and now i'm just going to make this
smaller again i'm actually going to
write another function so there's our
function check answers we're going to
get function get
results
or maybe add results because that's what
we're technically doing
adding the result into the answer
display
so function add result well what do we
want to do
well this time i'm actually going to
based on the question box we are in
so when do we want to call this function
i guess we want to call it
after here right we want to do it
here
or if we do it
based on so if we are if it's the
correct answer we're going to add the
score and we can pass through the actual
question
box
right because we want to add it to the
question
box
yeah so let's get the
or we could do answer display
yeah let's pass through the answer
display so you've got the question box
i'm going to pass through the answer
display as well into check answer and
we're going to say that we're going to
add the results to the answer display
and that result is going to correct
okay which means that again we can just
use the same
function to pass through
different variables to change the
outcome so let's have this say wrong
okay so this means that we know we're
passing through the answer display and
we're also going to pass through the
actual
answer
okay so this means we can grab the
answer display
and then we can
use text content in fact we probably
want to clear anything that's in there
right because we otherwise would just be
adding more we will be adding correct
wrong correct wrong depending on which
one we click because we'll just keep
adding so we want to clear anything
that's in it
and then we want to get the answer
display text content
and choose to put the answer that we
pass through okay as the second
parameter
okay so
we're going to either pass you correct
or wrong depending on
if we're here or if we're
here
okay so that's all i am
going to do
and i feel this should be it because
we're already putting in the
onto display
into the question box up here but let's
check it out
so jury
let's see onto display
no it seems we are not
putting that in here
answer
display answer display just to see what
we are clicking
so if we click on here
answer display adjacent
ah
because we're adding the answer display
here
because it needs to be after the options
we can't then obviously add it in here
that's my bad
so what i'm going to do instead is pass
through the question box we've just
created
into check answer because we can pass
that through
and then that means we are passing that
through into check answer so let's get
rid of this
and pass through the question box which
means that on the add result we're going
to pass through the question box pass
through the question box
this is a question box and it means that
we are going to get question box
and get
the uh or we can use query selector as
your query selector to find
the div with the class name
of answer
display so before if you notice uh
this
looking in the entire document you can
actually just look in a uh element so
that's what i've done here and let's
save this
as
answer
display so we don't want document again
we want to look in the
question box
okay cool in fact we might not actually
need this because it overrides it so
just get rid of that
and
great
so this is looking good one last thing i
want to do in that is just change the
color of this based on if it's right or
wrong but this is super super simple all
i'm going to do is of course get the
answer display
i'm just going to remove any class list
that might exist so if wrong exists
i want to remove it because otherwise it
will just add
you know
it might cause some funky issues
so remove if there's a wrong class or a
correct class remove both of those
and i'm gonna
get the
answer display and use class
list ad and i'm just going to add
well actually we can just pass it
through in here to make our lives easier
so the class name i want to add is
correct and if it's wrong the class name
i want to add is wrong
so i'm going to pass through class name
and just use that to add a class name
and this also means of course we need to
do it here so we can make sure that it's
just on the answer display if i do
correct
so there you go this means that it's on
the same day the class is on anything
with the class answer display
and the color of the text
is going to be rgb
2 1 1 2 1
1
1 7
and then i'm also going to do
onto display
wrong
and wrong is going to be
two one one one three four one one
seven
okay
so
great
there
we
go
we have now finished our game okay
it's kind of foolproof because we are
disabling buttons so you can't cheat i
don't think
but let me know what you think of this
game
okay
so wonderful we've just finished our
game in pure vanilla javascript if you
are interested in taking this a step
further and you'd like to learn how to
use apis in order to get random
questions and please do check out the
video as i said in the description below
for this on my own channel
okay so i'm gonna start off on webstorm
which is my ide of choice it's the code
editor that i'm gonna be using today and
i'm just gonna click new project right
here and let's call this jeopardy so
jeopardy
vanilla
js
just like so and i'm just gonna click
create
so there you will see a directory has
been created for me of course there is
nothing in this directory at the moment
we're to have to add some files so i'm
just going to go ahead and add a new
file there's going to be an html file
i'm just going to call it index and
select that it's a html file now if you
aren't using webstorm you will have to
put the extension so that your code
editor knows to treat this as a html
file but we are using webstorm so i'm
just going to go like that
great
and now let's call our project something
this is what it's going to display in
the browser so i'm just going to go
ahead and call this
jeopardy
and now let's
create some more files because we're
going to have to sort our styles
somewhere so i'm just going to go in
here create a new file this time it's
going to do a style sheet it's a css
file i'm going to call this styles and
select that it's a css file so there we
go and you can see the extension has
been added
wonderful and one more file this is
going to hold our javascript and i'm
just going to call it app and as you
will see the js extension has been added
so that our code editor knows to treat
this as a javascript file
great
okay
now i'm just going to make this a little
bit bigger
we need to link up the two files we made
to the html file so we're going to do
this thanks to the link tag just like so
and the reference to this is just going
to be the path to my styles css file
which is in the root of my project so i
don't need to worry about going into any
directories or anything and it just
looks like that
and next we also need to link up our
javascript and we're going to do so with
a script tag and the source of this
we're also going to give the path to our
app.js file so just like
that okay making sure that it's above
any html that we write because this
needs to be loaded first
now
in here i'm just simply going to put the
bare minimum of what we need and that is
going to be an h1 tag that's going to
say let's
play
jeffree
okay so just like that
and i'm going to now make a div
that is going to hold
all of the game in it okay we're going
to be injecting stuff with javascript
into here so we of course need to pick
this out and which is why i'm going to
give this the id
of
game okay i'm going to be injecting
stuff with our javascript we're going to
be injecting it exactly in here in
between these two divs but i will show
you that later on
so we've got the div with the id of game
the next thing i'm going to do is just
put an h2 tag that's going to show our
score and i'm going to use a span tag so
that we can
add in the score dynamically later on
okay so for to do this i'm going to pick
this out i'm going to pick it out
um in my javascript which is why i've
given it the id and i'm just going to
give this the idea of score okay so by
using the span it will just interrupt
this h2 tag and it'll appear just like
one sentence
great
so now that we've done that in webstorm
i can just click this button and it will
open up the game and the browser for me
or if you're not using webstorm you can
just open this up by yourself you just
need to right click here copy the path
make sure it's the absolute path
and then just paste that in your browser
like so so you're literally going to
wherever your index html file is on your
computer okay and opening it up
great and if i inspect the page this
will allow me to get out my console log
to carry on coding
so let's carry on coding let's get to
adding our elements with javascript into
here so to do this i'm of course going
to pick out this div i'm going to pick
it out based by its id and i'm going to
do the same for this one right here so
the span element too
so in here we're going to use document
get element i can do by id why not by id
game and i'm going to save this as
something what should we choose to save
as
let's just save it as okay
and let's do the same for the score so
i'm going to call this score display
document get element by id and the id
was score
so now we've essentially saved these two
elements so the span
and this so that we can work with it in
our javascript based on these const
okay
great
so before we carry on let's actually get
some data so of course we are just
making a game using vanilla javascript
if you do want to learn how to use apis
build out a backend and so on
i do have a link to making this exact
same game just with a open api
so we won't have to do any back-end work
for this particular one but i'll show
you how to use fetch and just make an
api request in order to get a lot more
data that we're going to be hard coding
in here okay so we're just going to hard
code an array of genres five genres that
have three questions each
so jeopardy
category i'm going to save this as
categories
and this array is going to hold
essentially our
categories so the genre the first genre
is going to be who
and then each genre is also going to
have its own questions which is going to
be an array
of objects so there's going to be fun
there's going to be a lot of like
interesting stuff that we're going to be
working with today especially if you're
new to working with arrays and objects
and data
so the next genre i'm going to actually
have as where
and i'm just going to have an empty
array for the questions as well
okay and we're going to have five of
these
in fact i'm just going to show you what
the first object looks like because all
five are going to have the same kind of
shape
so the questions in my questions array
like i said there's going to be three
questions each each one is going to be
symbolized by an object and the object
is going to look like this it's going to
have the question itself so for example
we can have who wrote harry
potter
that's my question
and then of course we'll have two
answers we can choose from so i know in
jeopardy you just want to shout out the
answer but of course this is an online
game so i've just chosen to have two
answers available to the user playing
and then we'll show the correct answer
so jk rowling's one answer and then
we're going to have j r
told kian as the second answer and then
we're also going to have the correct
answer which in this case is going to be
jk rowling making sure to spell exactly
the same otherwise this will cause
issues even with the capital letters and
so on it needs to be exact and then the
level we're going to have easy
okay so this is what we're going to have
this is how our question's going to look
we're going to have three in each
object genre
so i've actually pre-done this for you
because you don't really want to
sit here watching me type out all the
data i presume so i'm going to just
paste it in here like so
so
there we go as always this will be
available in the description below the
final code will be available so please
don't worry
so i'm just going to talk you through
this under the genre who we have an
array of questions so here's the opening
uh bracket to our array and there's
three questions one with level easy one
with level medium and one level hard and
then we got the next object which is
exactly the same this time the genre is
where though and the questions are more
around where but again they have the
answers available the correct answer
which is exactly the same down to the uh
capitals and not capitals and then the
level and then we have when
and then we have what
and then we have how many
okay so please feel free to pause here
and have a look at this data once again
get it from the description just make
sure you're comfortable with it before
we carry on working with this data in
order to build out our jeopardy okay
so the first thing i want to do is add a
category right so we've got our five
jeopardy categories
and i'm going to use each of the
categories in order to create a column
the column is going to have the name of
the category and then each three of the
questions okay
so that's what i'm going to do there's
going to be a lot of for each and loops
in loops
okay because we're going to loop out
five columns i'm going to
loop in each column the questions and so
on so i'm going to show you how to do
that now let's go and get to writing our
first
function
so i'm going to write function
add
category
and what do we want to do
well actually let's get this array
i'm going to get the jeopardy categories
jeopardy categories and for each
let's call it a category
i'm just going to pass it through
into the add category function okay
so essentially all of this
here's our first category right from
here to here all of this is being passed
through now
into
this ad category function but we're not
doing anything with it yet let's
actually pass it through
now we need to get the category genre
first okay so that's what we're going to
do and we're going to make a title
element with it
so
let's do it
so the first thing i'm going to do is
actually use document create element in
order to create a div
and let's save this as something i'm
going to call this as a column
okay we're going to create a column
and in fact we're going to get that
column and use class let's add the class
of columns so we can style it up later
in our style sheet so it actually looks
more like a column and not just a div in
fact maybe let's be more precise and
call this genre column like so
so we made a div the first thing i said
we want to put in the column is a like a
div for a title so i'm just going to
use document create element div again
thank you tab nine and let's call this
genre title
and this time genre title let's give it
class list add genre title so we can
again style it up
and i'm just going to use inner text to
actually
give it the genre name so like i said
we're going into here
and getting the genre
okay so we're getting the string of who
and then what and why and so on so all
five categories
so that's all i'm doing even though at
the moment you won't see anything in the
browser right because we've created
elements we give them class names we put
some text inside them okay we've done
all that but we haven't actually put it
back into our html have we we need to do
that now
so this is why i picked out the
game so this is where i picked up this
because i want to put my first five
columns that i'm making into here
so i'm gonna do so
like so i'm gonna loop over so as soon
as i make a column i'm going to get the
game i'm going to use append to put in
the
column we just
made
so that will loop
for each time we have that so we'll go
five times i'll add a column and i'll
add another column five times that will
do it but our column also needs to have
all of this in it right so i'm gonna get
the column before we put it back in the
game
column and i'm going to append
the genre title in it
so now if we look in the browser
and i'm just going to show you what this
looks like in html now so that's what we
made before remember that's what we
wrote in our html but with the thanks of
javascript i put in
five divs that have the class of genre
column and each one have another div
with a cluster and a title and the genre
itself
so we've done it
okay we've done our first four each in
order to create elements using
javascript
take a break here let that soak in
because we are going to be doing this
again like i said to add in each of the
three questions into each column
uh and first off let's actually take a
mental break with some styling because
starting is really nice it's really easy
and i'll allow our brains to maybe you
know
slow down a bit a bit before we do
another for each again
so
first things first i'm just going to
start the body up by getting rid of any
margin and padding
just to make sure that it's you know
spread out
uh all over and i'm gonna give it a
background color
it's rgb this kind of
well i'll show you
or six
it's kind of like a dark
gray that i'm going to be using and the
font that i want to use in here is also
all the font all the text sorry it's
going to be
white just so it stands out
the next thing i want to do is actually
use flexbox in order to make sure that
everything is displayed in the center
so by initializing flexbox i can now use
this command which is justify content
center i won't be able to use it without
display flex so make sure display flex
is there and align item center as well
that's something i'm going to use as
well as flex direction
flex direction column to make sure it's
stacked over each other
okay
and
great i'm also going to actually import
a font family
that is outside of what we have so if
you go over to font awesome
so if you go over to google fonts
the font i want to choose is called
anton so i'm just going to search for it
i've already
been using some here i don't actually
want any of these so let's go ahead and
just
remove oswald
remove all
anton
so this is the one that i want so please
go ahead and click that and just select
this type there's only one style and you
can choose whether to do it in your html
or css i'm going to choose to put it in
my css file
i'm going to copy that and at the top of
this file i'm going to import it like so
as a url and that just means that i can
now use it
next to this
so great
so i can now use the font family anton
with sans serif as a backup
wonderful so that is my body it just
means that i've kind of styled
everything up to look a bit more like
this the next thing i actually want to
style is the uh game so let's pick out
this div by the id of game so this means
i need to go for the id of game just
like so
and i'm just going to say that
everything in here is going to have
the background color
of rgb
like this kind of
a darker grayish color okay
so that's all i'm going to do
for now
the other thing i want to do is just
make sure that all of these columns are
actually stacked next to each other so
i'm also going to use display
flex to do this
and ta-da
that's what it should look like for now
of course we are going to be changing
all of this up a little bit
later
so what's the next thing we're going to
do well let's actually get to um
inserting cards in fact while we're here
let's actually just add the styling for
a card just so we can visually see
things a little bit nicer when they
happen
the width of a card i'm going to hard
code is 160 pixels
the height i'm going to hard code is 120
pixels uh the background color i'm just
going to make it be that that jeopardy
blue which is rgb2626255
now i'm gonna make it look beveled so
border left i'm gonna say solid rgb
uh and then it's gonna be like this kind
of lighter
blue color
that i picked out
earlier and it's going to be 10 pixels
thick and then i don't know if there's a
short hand way to do this but i'm lazy
so i'm just going to do that
left
right
and then we have
top
and
bottom
and then i'm just going to switch out
the colors
a little bit
so i'm going to make this
like a dark blue i'm going to make this
another tone of blue just to make it
look
beveled and then again same here so
great
i'm just going to make sure all the text
is centered too
and the font size i'm going to use for
the cards it's going to be 100 pixels
okay it's going to be really big let's
give it a margin of 5 pixels so each
card is going to have a margin of 5
pixels and some padding
and i'm also going to give the line i'm
going to change the line height
of the font okay so that's all i've done
so we created a class of card now let's
actually get you
creating some cards
so we've appended the column inside the
game the next thing we need to do is
actually work
with the
questions so at the moment we are still
in this object right we've picked out
the genre the next thing i want to do is
pick out this array of questions and
we're going to use four each again to
loop over each item in this array
so hopefully that makes sense based on
what we've done previously
so as we are currently for eaching so
we're in the for each loop currently
thanks to this
let's get a category
and all i'm going to do is get the
category
questions this time so the array
and for
each item
or each question sorry let's call it a
question
what do we want to happen well as i said
i want to make a card so document create
element div
and i'm just going to call this
literally
card just like so
and this time i'm going to go classless
a
card because that's the cut the class
that we have just created here so that's
what i want to apply to this
div and of course we need to put it in
the column so let's grab the
column
and use append
and i'm going to append the card
okay
great you can use a pen child append
allows you to add multiple things but
you can use a pen child if you want to
if you just want to append one thing
which i guess technically we are doing
here
so great that's what we are doing at the
moment we won't see much because it's
just an empty div however we can put
some text
in
here
uh in fact maybe let's do it by the
level so we're looping over each item in
the questions array right so i want to
get each questions level
and if it's easy
so
right here after we put in the card if
question
level
equals
easy
well then i want to get the card and
it's in a html or in a text
you can do whatever already in html in a
text the same thing maybe let's keep it
all consistent though so i know we did
it somewhere
here in a
html
we're just going to hard code 100
because that's how many points you get
for answering an easy question
and let's do the same for the others so
if it's medium
i want to put in the inner html 200
and if it's
hard i'm gonna give us 300 points
okay
so that's literally all i'm doing so now
if i look in here
that's what we have made that's our card
and that's the inner html that we've
given our card
this is looking
great
now if you watched my tutorial on making
a word association game in that game we
actually
you know had functions and we passed
through a lot of stuff into them in
order to work with event listeners so
we're passing through a lot of um
information into functions this time i'm
going to show you a different way to do
this you can actually set attributes to
elements so that you can add more data
to them that you can pick out later and
you can do so using the set attribute
method so this is what i'm going to be
showcasing for us today
okay i'm going to get up this because
we're going to be needing to see exactly
what i am adding to each div at the
moment each of these div just has the
class card and the inner html of 100 200
or 300 i'm gonna be adding a lot more
information to these with the help of
set attribute of course this doesn't
mean that someone could you know inspect
the page and cheat at jeopardy but you
know this is just for fun so but yeah
just be aware of that
so
i want to essentially append all the
information about my question to this
div so that we flip it we still have
access to that information
so like i said we're going to use set
attribute to do this so i'm going to
grab the card
so literally the card that we created
which is the div and that we added the
classes to and then we put in the column
and then we added in html too next we're
going to use set attribute in order to
add a data
question which is going to just be the
questions
question right because we're looping
over
this questions array which we called
question this is a question which is why
i've said question question
i mean
sadly you know it's just worked out that
way that we have to use question
question
next we're going to have question
correct and we're going to go into the
question object and get level and as
well as the first answer in the second
answer
so that's what we've done here and in
fact if i show you what this looks like
if i refresh it
you will now see that each div not only
has the class of card not only has the
inner text content of 100 it also has
now data question and the actual
question how many players in a football
team how many seconds an hour and how
many people in china so that information
is all attached to that div that we
can't visually see but it exists
so
i'm gonna do the same so card set
attribute for the other things i said so
we've got the data question
let's have the data
correct which is going to be question
correct and then also the answers right
so set attribute data
let's do answer one
and go question
aunt says and then go into the first get
the first item from this array so this
one and then let's get the second one as
well
i'm just going to copy this line
get the second item by using the index
value of one to enter this to get the
second item in the array
because as we know arrays use indexes
now i'm going to do one last thing and
you set attribute to add the data
value and you might be thinking like oh
what but we've used all the information
we can in here
what what else do you want to do right
well i actually want to get this value
and also set it to the div so that when
we flip the card we still know the value
of the card and i can do so with a
function so i can get the card and use
get
inner
html and call it so call the method in
order to get the inner html of this div
which in this case is 100 the case is
200 in this case it's 300.
so that's pretty
neat if i do say so
myself so now if i refresh this and we
look on any one of these
you will see the data question data
answer one data answer
correct and the data value why is there
data answer to not being added
ah it's because data aren't being
overwritten
so
ta-da
we have all that information as well as
the data of value now to our disposal
great
so now let's get to flipping these cards
so i'm going to do so by adding an event
listener to our card so card
add event listener and on click of the
card i just want to flip the card so
this is a callback function we need to
write this function and if we click on
any card this will be called okay but
only if we click on the card
so let's go ahead and do that
now
so we are done with this function it is
a long one so the function add category
is now done
the next function we're going to write
is the function
so function
flip
god
so what do we want to happen when we
flip the card well we just wanted to
visually look like we flipped the card
right so in fact i just want to get rid
of the styling of the
div so i want to get rid of this styling
and just make it look like i flip the
card by adding some animations maybe and
then you know having the question show
up with the two options of the answers
so let's do it
so i'm going to get this card so this
element that i've clicked on i'm going
to get it in html and i'm literally just
going to put an empty
string okay so it's kind of like a cheat
way to empty it out
now the next thing i want to do is
create a div that i've called text
display so that we can display the text
of the question in and then kind of
style it up a little bit so i'm going to
use create element and i'm going to
create a div to do this okay
so now that we've created the div once
again i'm going to get text display and
i'm going to use class list add to add a
class list that we are yet to write we
can use text display or maybe let's
choose card
text just like so
so we're putting in the text display
this is good the next thing i want to do
is add two buttons so once again i'm
going to use document
create element
and this time i'm going to create a
button element
and once we have created that button i'm
just going to call this first button
because i'm not very imaginative but we
actually need two buttons so first
button and second button again just
using the create element method to
create a button element
so once we have those well of course
we're gonna have to add
uh classes to them so thank you very
much but this first button is gonna have
the class first button and then the
second one is gonna have the class you
guessed it
second
button
so just like so
so we've added the classes and now we
just need to add some text into these
right so i'm going to go first button
in html and we are going to get this
whatever we clicked
this
get attribute
i'm gonna get the attribute let's have a
look again what's to our disposal get
attribute
[Music]
data answer one
answer
one and of course for the second one
we'll get data answer
two for the second
button so we created the buttons we've
added classes to the buttons we've also
set the inner html of the buttons to
either have one answer or another and of
course we need to put these buttons
into whatever we click so we're gonna
use this again
this keyword i'm gonna do append
and i'm actually gonna append
the text display
and then the first button and then the
second button
okay
great
so that is looking good we of course
also need to get the uh we need to add
in uh html we need to actually add the
uh question itself so we're going to use
get attribute
to get the data question
making sure to spell it exactly the same
as we saved it
so data question like
so
great
so this should now look good let's test
it out so let's well something's gone
wrong
event listener is not a function okay
card
our ad event list should be a capital l
here
okay so if we click on one now
so that is disappearing and we are
getting the question and we are getting
two buttons of course we need to do some
styling because this is not looking good
so one thing i can actually do is change
we're probably going to have to change
the font size in here so we can do so
using font style
this style font size
now let's change it to be 15 pixels
so again we're just using javascript
to do this and we're also going to
change the line height from here line
height is going to be 30
pixels so now if we click on one of
these
amazing so that is looking much
better there's of course still some
things we need to do one thing we need
to do is actually um add an on click to
these buttons to handle if it's the
correct answer or not and also i want to
disable clicking on any of these if we
are currently answering a question right
and we don't want to cheat
no cheating allowed and then we also
want to add one to the score if the
correct answer is clicked
so i'm going to show you how to do all
of that first off however let's get to
styling some things up the first thing
that i'm going to start up is the
buttons
so
let's do that
now i'm just going to make some space
and great
so the first button
i'm just gonna give this a background
color
of rgb
two four
one seven one two four we're gonna make
it look kind of like retro and then of
course the second button as well
needs to have some
styling too
so one let's go with one
90 57
37
so we just added two colors to the
buttons we can let's keep it this kind
of retro style though because i'm kind
of
strangely into it you don't have to of
course you can choose to get rid of it
if you wish
okay while we are here let's also style
the genre title
so the class of this was genre title if
i remember that correctly i'm going to
give it a background color of the same
blue that we had so
rgb
two six two six
two
five five like so
uh let's text align center
oops text
line
center
let's make the font size
i'm going to make it 28 pixels
let's give it padding
five pixels
okay and then also a margin
five pixels two
so that just looks a little bit more
like this just like
the game
great
okay
so we've done
that
the next thing i want to do is
handle the click so let's do that
so now what we want to do do you know
actually before we move on to adding the
event listeners for the two buttons i'm
actually going to say that if we flip
the card i want to get every single card
every single one and remove the event
listener so i'm going to use using
document query select all and look of
anything with the class of cards so
that'll be all
all of these cards okay all of these
and i'm going to remove the event
listener for them but only on this flip
so all cards i'm going to save this as
and i think we need to make this an
array
i'm going to make an array from
these
apologies if not make sure there's query
selector all
and then we're going to get all the
cards
and for each
[Music]
card
i'm just going to get each card and
remove
event listener i'm going to remove the
click and i'm going to remove the flip
card
so that now if a card is flipped
we can't click any of them the flip is
disabled this is cool right and i only
want to enable it again if we choose an
answer
so now let's handle the clicks of the
buttons
so i'm going to write another function
this function is going to be called uh
let's call it get
result
okay so just like so let's move all of
this
oops
let's just move all of this up a little
bit
so what do i want to happen
well i want to
if i click on the button right so let's
add an event listener to the first
let's do up here
first button add event listener if i
click on it then i want to get
results just as a callback function
okay and then let's do the same for the
second button as well so they're both
going to essentially call this function
if we click on them and if we click on
there i want to get this whatever i
clicked whatever button i clicked i want
to get his parents this parent is the
card so if we have a look at here the
button
lives in
the div with the class of cards i want
to get the parent of this right i want
to get the parent
so this parent
element so i'm just going to show you
the console
log
now let's say this is something const
card of button to be really precise
because that's what we're getting we're
getting the card the button belongs to
and then do we have any other console
logs in here i feel like we do
hmm we do not okay
so here's our console log so if i click
on this
click on a button it will show me
its parent which is this card that
belongs to and you'll see all that data
that we need to work with okay so that's
quite cool
let's carry on so to get the result well
what i'm going to do is say if
card of
button and i'm going to use get
attribute to get the attribute of
well i guess we want to get the data
correct
answer right we want to get the data
correct which is 11 so we know that this
is the correct answer we want to make
sure it's the same as the inner html of
the button
so if
that
equals this inner html then we know it's
a correct answer right so then we're
going to get the score
and we are going to essentially add the
score
by getting again um
the data value of the button
which is why we save the data value so
there we go so i'm going to once again
go card button get attribute data
value however it's a string right so we
need to pass this through pass int
to make sure that it's a number type
and then we're going to add it to the
score so score
plus
the value
i'm going to assign to the variable
score
okay
so are we actually saving score anywhere
here i don't believe we are
so i'm going to go let score equal
zero to start
okay so that's what we're doing if it's
if the answer is correct we're going to
add something to the score where they're
going to show the score
in the browser because we're actually
not doing that yet so just get the
variable of score after we've added the
data value to it and then show it in
here
the next thing i'm going to do is
actually
get the card button
and i'm going to also class list ad i'm
going to add a correct answer class so
that we can change
symbolize that's correct let's go like
an orange or something
and then let's uh actually remove
everything in the
card itself we're going to remove the
question we're going to move these two
buttons and we're just going to show the
value that we want if it's correct
so to do this i'm actually going to
leave a little bit of time so it's not
so abrupt okay so i'm going to use a set
timeout to do this
and then we're going to use a while loop
to essentially remove children we're
going to remove the last child and then
the last child until there's no children
left in the parent
div so while card of
button
first child exists it's going to keep
doing it until there's no first child
right so while that is true we're going
to get the card button remove child's
card button last child so we're going to
essentially if that makes sense we're
going to keep looping and get rid of the
last child get rid of the last shall get
rid of last child until the last child
is the first child get rid of that and
then there'll be no fast child and this
will kind of um finish running
okay so we're going to do that we're
going to move everything in it
and we're going to do this after 100
milliseconds and then we're just going
to get the
card button and then the in html like we
said we're just going to make it the
uh value so
get attribute
data value we're just going to show how
many points we won
so that's all what happens all of this
is what happens if you know the answer
is correct else
we're going to say wrong answer so i'm
essentially going to
just take this line
but this time wrong
answer so that'll be like a reddish
color maybe i haven't decided yet and
this time we're going to do set timeout
and then
we're actually still going to remove
everything
but this time we're just going to
add a
zero because we want zero points we can
do it as a number if you want it's
totally up to you and we're gonna do
this again after
milliseconds
okay great
and then afterwards we're gonna add back
we're actually
we need to add back all the event
listeners to the cards but also we're
going to remove
the event listener for this specific
card because we're done with it remove
event listener click flip card we're
done with this card we've got our points
no more cheating
and this just means that actually
um
let's
perhaps do it up here
so once again document queries get all
the cards again so everything with the
class name of card
and i'm going to save this as all cards
make an array from this again i'm not
really sure if i have to do this
i'm doing it now i've committed
uh and then
all cards for
each card
i'm going to well just add back in the
remove
the event listener
okay
great and then just some final styling
to add the correct answer and incorrect
answers so correct
answer it's the correct answer i want
the
background color
to change to rgb
186
186 24
and if it's a wrong answer
then i want to change the background
color
to be rgb
2 2 1
6 4
5 6.
great
so now let's check it out so this one
when is christmas i know it's here yay
it's correct so we see the value we get
a hundred to the score and the
backgrounds turn yellow
now this one what is the casper saudi
arabia i'm going to go with jeddah
that's the wrong answer by the way but i
should get a red zero points and zero is
added so this is looking wonderful and
of course i can't click on anything else
until i answer this question and then i
can click on another
question so even when this is here can't
click on anything
superman
wonderful
so this is looking fantastic we have now
finished our jeopardy
game so i hope you've enjoyed this
tutorial i've really enjoyed making this
for you i mean i think we've done a
really good job at this it is kind of
foolproof of course if you uh come
across any bugs then let me
know but i'm quite happy with
this
wow okay and of course please feel free
to style this up however you wish that
part is totally up to you
thanks so much again for watching and i
hope to see you again soon